THE FBI TODAY SEIZING THE CELL
PHONE OF A REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN WHO IS BEST KNOWN
FOR PUSHING A BOGUS CONSPIRACY
THEORY ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION.
HIS NAME IS SCOTT PERRY.
CNN'S SARA MURRAY JOINS US NOW
WITH MORE ON THAT STORY.
SO WHAT IS SCOTT PERRY SAYING
TONIGHT?
WELL, HE PUT OUT A LENGTHY
STATEMENT DESCRIBING WHAT
HAPPENED.
HE SAID, THIS MORNING WHILE
TRAVELING WITH MY FAMILY, THREE
FBI AGENTS VISITED ME AND SEIZED
MY CELL PHONE.
HE GOES ON TO SAY THIS CELL
PHONE IS FULL OF INFORMATION
ABOUT POLITICAL ACTIVITIES,
PERSONAL AND PRIVATE
DISCUSSIONS, LEGISLATIVE
ACTIVITIES, THINGS HE SAYS THAT
THE GOVERNMENT HAS NO BUSINESS
LOOKING INTO.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS WHAT THE
FBI IS INVESTIGATING THAT LED
THEM TO SCOTT PERRY'S CELL
PHONE.
WE KNOW THAT PERRY WAS, YOU
KNOW, INTEGRAL IN PUSHING DONALD
TRUMP'S CLAIMS OF ELECTION
FRAUD.
WE KNOW THAT HE ACTUALLY
INTRODUCED THE FORMER PRESIDENT
TO JEFFREY CLARK, WHO WAS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OFFICIAL
WHO WAS LITTLE KNOWN AT THE
TIME, WHO WAS WILLING TO GO
ALONG WITH DONALD TRUMP'S
ELECTION FRAUD CLAIMS AND
WILLING TO TRY TO STAGE A COUP
ESSENTIALLY AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
SO IT'S NOT CLEAR IF IT IS
PERHAPS RELATED TO THAT.
WE REPORTED EARLIER THIS SUMMER
THAT JEFFREY CLARK'S HOME WAS
SEARCHED, SO HE'S BEEN UNDER
SCRUTINY FROM INVESTIGATORS.
THE OTHER THING WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH SCOTT
PERRY'S PHONE IS WHAT
INVESTIGATORS WILL BE ABLE TO
GET FROM IT.
CNN PREVIOUSLY REPORTED THAT
PERRY HAD HAD A NUMBER OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH MARK MEADOWS,
THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF, AND IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS,
THEY USED AN ENCRYPTED MESSAGING
APP.
SO WE DON'T KNOW IF THOSE
MESSAGES COULD STILL BE ON HIS
PHONE.
>> THEY USED SIGNAL, WASN'T IT?
>> Reporter: RIGHT.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THOSE COULD
STIM BE ON SCOTT PERRY'S PHONES
AND IF THAT'S WHAT INVESTIGATORS
WERE LOOKING FOR OR SOMETHING
ELSE YAALTOGETHER.
A BIG DEAL THEY'RE COMING FOR A
SITTING CONGRESSMAN'S CELL
PHONE.
>> I WANT TO GET PERSPECTIVE NOW
ON THE LEGAL AND POLITICAL
IMPACTS OF ALL THESE STORIES.
JOINING US TONIGHT IS CNN CHIEF
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT AND
INSIDE POLITICS ANCHOR JOHN
KING, CNN LEGAL ANALYST ELLIOT
WILLIAMS, AND CNN CHIEF
POLITICAL ANALYST GLORIA BORGER.
HOW SIGNIFICANT ARE THESE NEW
DETAILS?
THE SEARCH CAME AFTER SUSPICIONS
OF WITHHELD MATERIALS, THAT
DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO HAD
NATIONAL SECURITY IMPLICATIONS.
>> WELL, WE HAVE MORE OF A
SKETCH NOW.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE KEY
INFORMATION.
WHAT DO THEY MEAN BY NATIONAL
SECURITY IMPLICATIONS?
HOW MANY DOCUMENTS?
WHAT DO THEY RELATE TO?
BUT WE NOW AT LEAST HAVE A
BROADER SKETCH OF THE URGENCY
THAT CONVINCED THE FBI AND THEN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, ALL THE
WAY UP TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
TO TAKE THIS UNPRECEDENTED STEP,
TO SERVE A SEARCH WARRANT AT THE
HOME OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
LOOK, MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT,
ANDERSON.
AT SOME POINT, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WILL FACE A
CREDIBILITY TEST BOTH IN COURT
AND IN PUBLIC OPINION.
THAT DAY SHOULD NOT BE TODAY.
WE ARE EARLY IN AN INVESTIGATION
OR WE'RE AT SOME POINT IN AN
INVESTIGATION WHERE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SAYS IT CAN'T TALK TO
US JUST YET.
BUT THE FACT THAT THEY TOOK THE
EXTRAORDINARY NATURE SUGGESTS
THIS WAS A 15-MONTH PROCESS.
MANY COMMUNICATIONS WITH TRUMP
AND WITH HIS LAWYERS, INCLUDING
A MEETING IN JUNE THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT STOPPED IN.
SO SOMETHING HAPPENED BETWEEN
JUNE AND AUGUST WHERE THE FBI
SAW A REASON -- WE DON'T KNOW
THE SPECIFICS -- TO BELIEVE
SOMETHING WAS AT RISK, SOME
DOCUMENT WAS AT THREAT.
AND JUST VERY QUICKLY ON THIS
POINT THAT TRUMP HAS THE POWER
TO DECLASSIFY RECORDS, THAT'S
TRUE, A, BUT THERE'S A PROCESS.
AND, B, EVEN IF HE DECLASSIFIED
EVERYTHING, THEY DON'T BELONG TO
HIM.
THE RECORDS ACT IS VERY CLEAR.
THE DOCUMENTS BELONG TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEY GO TO
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES, PERIOD.
>> IT'S ALSO REMARKABLE, JOHN
KING, BASED ON HIS CRITICISM OF
OTHERS OVER THE YEARS ON
HANDLING EMAILS OR, YOU KNOW,
ALLEGED SECURITY VIOLATIONS.
>> IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
INTELLECTUAL CONSISTENCY HERE,
ANDERSON, YOU CAME TO THE WRONG
TOWN IN THE SENSE THAT IF YOU
LISTEN TO DONALD TRUMP AND YOU
LISTEN TO HIS REPUBLICAN ALLIES,
THEY REMEMBER HILLARY CLINTON
SHOULD BE ABOUT SIX YEARS INTO
HER PRISON SENTENCE AT
LEAVENWORTH BECAUSE SHE SET UP A
SERVER AT HOME THAT MIGHT HAVE
SENSITIVE INFORMATION GO THROUGH
IT, THAT IT WAS POSSIBLE THE
CHINESE OR RUSSIANS COULD HACK
INTO.
THEY RAISED THAT AT THE POINT.
THAT WAS A JUDGMENT ERROR BY
SECRETARY CLINTON.
I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND HILLARY
CLINTON'S EMAIL SERVER.
BUT DONALD TRUMP, SHOULD HE RUN
FOR PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AGAIN, DONALD TRUMP IS
INNOCENT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
OVERSTRETCHING.
THIS IS POLITICAL USE OF THE
INVESTIGATIVE POWERS.
THERE IS ZERO INTELLECTUAL
CONSISTENCY IN TRUMP'S ARGUMENT
OR THAT OF HIS REPUBLICAN ALLIES
AT THE MOMENT.
>> ELLIOT, FROM A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE, WHAT DO THESE
DEVELOPMENTS TELL YOU?
>> I THINK THE NEWEST
DEVELOPMENT TODAY IS THIS IDEA
OF PEOPLE IN TRUMP'S ORBIT NOT
BEING HONEST OR CANDID OR
FORTHCOMING WITH INFORMATION
WHEN ASKED.
LOOK, IT IS A CRIME TO GIVE A
FALSE STATEMENT TO A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
THAT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE UNDER
OATH OR SWORN OR, YOU KNOW, WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PERJURY OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IF AN AGENT IS TRYING TO FIND
OUT WHERE DOCUMENTS ARE AND YOU
LIE TO THAT AGENT, THAT IS A
CRIME.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, ANDERSON,
OF COURSE THERE'S THE RAFT OF
POSSIBLE CRIMES THAT MIGHT BE
INVESTIGATED HERE INVOLVING SORT
OF MISHANDLING OR MUTILATING OR
TEARING UP DOCUMENTS AND SO ON.
SO THE NEWEST THING TODAY BY FAR
IS THIS ALLEGATION OF
DISHONESTY.
BUT, AGAIN, ALL OF THESE CRIMES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
POSSIBLY BEING INVESTIGATED ARE
INCREDIBLY SERIOUS AND REASON
FOR CONCERN AND ALARM.
>> GLORIA, I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
SOME NEW REPORTING ABOUT HOW THE
SEARCH COULD BE PUSHING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT TO SPEED UP A
2024 ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> RIGHT.
A GROUP OF MY COLLEAGUES AND I
ARE REPORTING THIS EVENING THAT
SOME TOP REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE
SPENT AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME THESE
PAST MONTHS TRYING TO TELL
DONALD TRUMP, DON'T DECLARE FOR
THE PRESIDENCY UNTIL AFTER THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS BECAUSE THEY
WERE WORRIED HE WAS GOING TO BE
A DIVISIVE FIGURE, ARE NOW
CHANGING THEIR MINDS AND THAT
EVEN ONE TOP REPUBLICAN HAS
CALLED HIM UP, AT LEAST ONE, AND
SAID, YOU KNOW, I'M REALLY
THINKING YOU OUGHT TO DO IT NOW.
AND THE REASON IS THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, IT SEEMS, HAS
BEEN SO UNITED WITH HIM, AND
THEY BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
ANOTHER ISSUE FOR THEM TO TALK
ABOUT ASIDE FROM THE 2020
ELECTION, WHICH WAS DONALD
TRUMP'S FAVORITE ISSUE, BUT NOW
THIS COULD BECOME HIS ISSUE, AND
HE CAN PORTRAY HIMSELF AS THE
VICTIM, AS THE LEADER OF PEOPLE
WHO FEEL VICTIMIZED IN THIS
COUNTRY AND DON'T LIKE THE DEEP
STATE, AND THAT THIS WOULD GIVE
THEIR PEOPLE MORE MOMENTUM THAN,
IN FACT, THE DEMOCRATS MIGHT
HAVE, SAY, BECAUSE OF THE
ROE-WADE DECISION OR THEY'RE
SICK OF DONALD TRUMP, SO THEY'RE
NOW CHANGING THEIR TIMES.
>> JOHN, THERE'S NEW REPORTING
FROM "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
TONIGHT THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DISMISSED A PUSH FROM
SOME OF HIS ADVISERS TODAY TO
FLY BACK TO MAR-A-LAGO AND
IMMEDIATELY ANNOUNCE A NEW
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
>> LOOK, THIS CALCULATION, A, DO
YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
OUTRAGE AMONG YOUR SUPPORTERS TO
ANNOUNCE NOW?
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS, ANDERSON,
ARE 90 DAYS AWAY.
I THINK ANY SPECULATION ABOUT
HOW THIS COULD IMPACT 2024 LET
ALONE 2022 IS PREMATURE.
THREE MONTHS AGO THE DEMOCRATS
WERE IN A MESS.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN BETTER
SHAPE.
THAT'S JUST THIS YEAR.
BUT THE IDEA THAT TRUMP COULD
PLAY VICTIM AND USE THIS TO
SOMEHOW BLOCK OUT RIVALS IN
2024, THAT'S THE THINKING OF
SOME OF HIS PEOPLE.
THAT IS BECAUSE THEY PLAY ON THE
POWER OF GRIEVANCE, AND NOW THEY
BELIEVE THEY HAVE A GRIEVANCE.
BUT WE HAVE NO FACTS ON THE
TABLE.
SO THAT IS THEIR POLITICAL
CALCULATION.
IF HE ANNOUNCES HE'S RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT NOW, IT CHANGES HOW HE
CAN RAISE MONEY, HOW HE CAN MOVE
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
SO IT GIVES HIM SOME BENEFITS IN
CLAIMING POLITICAL GRIEVANCE AND
CLAIMING I'M A CANDIDATE, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SHOULDN'T
CHASE ME DOWN.
THIS HAS BEEN AN ONGOING DRAMA
IN TRUMP LAND.
TODAY IT IS HE SHOULD RUSH HOME
AND ANNOUNCE.
THERE WILL BE ANOTHER STORY
TOMORROW AND EVENTUALLY HE'LL
SAY SOMETHING, AND THAT'S WHEN
WE'LL START THE CLOCK.
>> ELLIOT, IS IT ACCURATE THAT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS
LEGAL TEAM WOULD GET A COPY OF
THE WARRANT WHICH HE COULD
RELEASE TO THE PUBLIC?
ISN'T THE WARRANT REQUIRED TO
LIST EVERYTHING THEY ANTICIPATE
FINDING OR CAN SOME OF IT BE
SEALED?
>> THE WARRANT IS JUST AN
ADMINISTRATIVE DOCUMENT THAT
SAYS, WE BELIEVE THERE'S
EVIDENCE OF A CRIME HERE.
IT'S GOT THE SIGNATURE ON IT.
BUT THE GOOD STUFF, ANDERSON,
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, IS IN
THE AFFIDAVITS AND APPLICATIONS
FOR THE WARRANT.
NOW, LOOK, HE GETS AN INVENTORY
OF ALL OF THE MATERIALS THAT
WERE SEIZED FROM HIS PROPERTY.
IF HE REALLY IS SAYING THAT
THESE ARE DECLASSIFIED OR
UNIMPORTANT DOCUMENTS OR JUST,
YOU KNOW, MEMENTOS FROM HIS TRIP
TO FUNLAINLAND, HE CAN RELEASE .
BUT ALL OF THE DOCUMENTATION
THAT REALLY DIGS IN AS TO WHAT
THE PUBLIC WANTS TO SEE ISN'T
GOING TO BE SEEN EITHER UNTIL
SOMEONE IS CHARGED WITH A CRIME
OR THE BASIS FOR KEEPING IT
SECRET GOES AWAY AND WHEN AN
INVESTIGATION IS CLOSED.
>> GLORIA, I MEAN, DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE MIDTERMS OR TOO
SOON TO TELL?
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S COME OF
THIS.
>> I THINK IT'S REALLY TOO SOON
TO TELL OTHER THAN WHEN YOU TALK
TO REPUBLICANS WHO ARE SAYING --
ONE REPUBLICAN WHO'S VERY CLOSE
TO DONALD TRUMP SAID TO ME
TODAY, I HAVE NOT SEEN THE PARTY
THIS UNIFIED BEHIND SOMETHING IN
A LONG TIME.
I MEAN, WHEN DO YOU SEE DeSANTIS
AND PENCE ON THE SAME PAGE
DEFENDING TRUMP?
AND THEY BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
ENOUGH OF A LEAD TIME THAT THIS
COULD AFFECT AND COULD MOTIVATE
REPUBLICAN VOTERS, WHICH THEY'VE
BEEN KIND OF WORRIED ABOUT,
PARTICULARLY IF DONALD TRUMP
WERE TO ANNOUNCE BECAUSE HE'S
BEEN SO DIVISIVE.
BUT IT'S EARLY AS JOHN WAS
SAYING, AND WE'RE JUST GOING TO
HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE HOW THIS
PLAYS OUT.
>> YEAH.
>> THE ADVANTAGE THEY HAVE, OF
COURSE, IS THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ISN'T GOING TO SAY
ANYTHING IN RETURN.
>> YEAH.
>> SO THEY CAN PUNCH AND PUNCH
AND PUNCH, AND IT'S VERY LIKELY
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL
STAY SILENT.
>> GLORIA BORGER, JOHN KING,
ELLIOT WILLIAMS, THANK YOU.